and it's my pleasure to welcome
my fellow friend colleague mr soham
biswas who just like all of you guys
once was someone who knew nothing about
bioinformatics just like me because we
were friends so
we got introduced to bioinformatics we
started learning what it is started
doing it from scratch just like a newbie
but later on soham went on to crack the
gate
get competition he won a gate
scholarship and now he is pursuing mtech
in bioinformatics from the university of
hyderabad so it's my great pleasure to
welcome today mr sloan bismus who is a
graduate student again pursuing masters
of technology in bioinformatics at the
university of hyderabad india with a
gate scholarship funded by the
government of india currently he is
involved in various research projects
that include predicting protein protein
interaction network and
other things in leishmania proteomes his
research interests include molecular and
structural biology network biology
and machine learning so it's such a
wonderful opportunity to listen to
someone from your perspective who has
gone through all of this and now he is
doing his own research implementing this
cutting-edge technologies in his work
and let's hear from him how his journey
has been how he feels right now what are
the various projects that he's working
on
and
really listen to
what he feels about being a
bioinformatician in the 21st century so
without any further ado i with all my
pleasure welcome mr soham biswas to
present about his research today so
suham thank you for joining us today and
the stage is all yours
thank you so much subraject it's a
really
wonderful opportunity for me to be here
as a
speaker and of course uh
i would like to convey
uh my warm records to the ender
organizing
um i mean today to all the organizers
so
yeah i mean i guess i'm now going to
go and show my screen
yes sure we are looking forward to
listen to you
[Applause]
[Music]
so yeah uh am i audible and is it
visible my
screen
yep your audible and your screen is also
visible you're good to go
thank you
so um yes uh for uh very first uh about
a brief introduction so yeah uh
shubhajit already told about me
so i am sohambishwas and i'm
currently pursuing m tech bioinformatics
from university of hyderabad
and of course uh like i mean
we would be at subrajit uh had a
great chance in
uh i mean during our uh
during our
undergraduate studies
and we had some
uh work together with uh fine biotech
so yes uh it's uh
i mean it's like a
get together again uh for me here to i
mean
to be here and uh speak in front of you
so yes uh right now i am doing my
dissertation uh from the molecular and
structural biology laboratory in the
department of biotechnology and
bioinformatics at the university of
hyderabad and you can uh search
you can search in uh frontiers about our
biotechnology about our department so we
have we mainly focus
on
infectious diseases like malaria or
leash meniscus and even our laboratory
has characterized various proteins uh
which are
very much crucial for the pathogenesis
of leash mania and also
our from our lab several protein
structures have been submitted in the
pdb and also
there are many
i mean there are many new proteins
have been characterized and the
sequences of all these have been
submitted to ncbi and um uniprot and
they are again uh very well key noted
so
here i will talk briefly about uh my
journey uh of course uh when i uh
started uh my education and and the
first
in the very first uh i was
i was i was having my undergraduate
study in biotechnology and it was the
particular time around february 2019 uh
when i first met
a team by biotech uh during a workshop
and
later on
i started
uh studying about bioinformatics and at
the very first i was completely zero in
bioinformatics and i had no uh basically
no knowledge but yes um during the
course of uh
working with bind biotech and uh also uh
and and also studying various courses
from uh
from their education platform i learned
a lot and it had a really really uh
change to my
study track
so
after that of course i had a chance for
become the campus ambassador
at
my
university campus
from pine biotech and later uh in the
around like september 2020 i
write i wrote the gate examination which
is a competitive examination for
higher studies so and and i had an
opportunity to have uh
i mean to have a graduation i do have a
postgrad um
degree at the university of hyderabad
and with a get fellowship directly
funded by the government of india
so and recently i am from the august
2021 onwards i am doing my one-year
dissertation project
at the university campus and my current
research uh is to build a protein
protein interaction network or
uh basically i can say the protein
protein direction network of the entire
proteome of two different leash manure
species one is leishwani in phantom and
the other one is leishmania major
so if i
start from the very scratch and
what my experience was with uh fine
biotic so i would say that it was uh
kind of uh from very basic level and uh
precisely from very zero level
so
i started uh
the i'm taking the courses from the
very much an interactive platform within
bind biotech and later i had a
chance to have and
for to have a capstone project and
basically this capstone project was my
first in
bioinformatics
and one of the thing is that
during this particular time
i had
lots of hands-on experience experiments
uh when
i mean from pinebiotec server and
this uh i mean
server.tbion.info it's a really really
great server for a hands-on experiments
and we can do a lot of uh bioinformatics
or data analysis uh there and yes i
really uh enjoyed uh those
particular
pipelines and the uh running the
algorithms
so if i very uh briefly uh tell about uh
my
first bioinformatics project it was a
part of a very uh it was a part of a
large project where our team was
interested in
identification of biomarkers within
ovarian cancer and my
uh
my part was
to have
to study how to identify some iso forms
with differential expressed genes and to
segregate those
isoforms and to segregate those isoforms
into by different parameters and to
check that if there is any relation or
correlation between
the stages of the cancer and the
differentially expressed
isoforms
and also if there is any correlation
between these two and the edges of the
patients
or basically if i say that at the first
time when the cancer was being
diagnosed
so here uh was a particular problem
statement that i already stated is that
to find relation between the patient age
and the clinical stage of the cancer
by integrating the differentially
expressed isoforms
and of course uh i will not uh go into a
very very uh detailed manner i will just
say it very briefly that what we have
done so yes the first thing what we have
done is that the data collection so we
extensively collected some data from
tcga and of course from firebrowse which
have the very clinical data with the
different different informations like
age in the clinical stage and basically
uh specifically at the stage where when
the when the first cancer was diagnosed
um
and then it would give some
rna-seq data so we collected those
analytic data and some
are same values related to those rna-seq
data and of course we had to process
those data before
analyzing
this particular data and come to a
biological medical conclusion
so um about this uh data analysis part
our
general workflow
was
basically divided in two
sections
so
one section was that
we were
simply finding what are the
differentially expressed genes
among
all the coming among all the collected
samples and which are which already have
been grouped by stage and after
we have identified that which particular
gene is expressing uh differentially
maybe it can have an over expression or
maybe it can have a
low expression level then uh we went to
uh find
if there is any significance level uh
within the isoforms of the same gene or
not
so here
we can uh here we
basically we
um worked with the server platform
provided by
pine biotech and we applied the
algorithm of de-seek to which is uh
differentially expression
to find the differential expression
um levels and different different uh and
of course differentially different
different expression levels of different
genes and isoforms so the server bio and
the server
is basically a very easy to
handle and you just have to click uh
some
of these i mean
i mean um very uh
you just have to click some other
buttons or which which are just
previously designed and pre-built so you
don't need to
code anything uh extensively like in
r or python
so uh uh this was now uh this was my
first i mean uh this was my first uh ex
i mean uh uh bioinformatics uh project
uh and uh with and and it it gave me a
lot of um
like experience that how to
particularly collect the data and how to
uh
have literature studies and text mining
and very precisely i would say the data
mining because data mining is a
particular approach and very crucial
approach in bioinformatics because in
bioinformatics you have to know that
what you are looking at and of course
what you are looking for so the first
and foremost thing is that yes you have
to have a very good collection of data
and then you need to know uh you need to
build your strategy or pipeline that how
you can proceed
uh with your
experiment
and of course after the data analysis
part
which can have uh different uh like
uh with with different algorithms or
maybe you can have to uh code a little
bit
but
after all you have to you have to know
that i mean
whatever conclusion you have that
you have reached to a biologically
meaningful conclusion
so after uh pine biotic right now i am
working with protein protein interaction
network of lishvania proteomes and as i
said uh previously that i am currently
working with two uh leash mania species
one is ishmaeli in phantom and another
is ishmania
major and what uh uh our uh project is
about is that the leash mania
pathogenesis if you study uh leash mania
pathogenesis then we would say that
lispania are of different types and the
thing is that these are different and
they have different pathways of the
pathogenesis so these different pathways
will vary depending on the
positive species and there are more than
20 species under the same leash many
agendas and they have different
taxonomical categories and they have a
different
way of
interacting within their
i mean i mean
within within their proteomes and of
course uh with the
human with the human proteins
so
our major
interest is to find a new drug target
and this is in leishmania in any leisure
research this is one of the most uh i
mean this is one of the most uh
difficult challenge because right now
the world is uh
the world is facing a very
important aspect is that is that about
leash money and not only leash money
about any of the diseases is that
the drugs are
getting parasitic resistance and in case
of leash mania of course there is no
vaccine and one of the uh very
um
very vital the thing is thing is to
overcome the drug side effects also in
case of leash mania so
that's why this uh building i mean this
uh building of protein protein
interaction network plays a very
important role
and and of course uh
in current days we have a lot of
computational approaches and of course
uh there have been and and and of course
this um artificial intelligence and
machine learning
can
uh
can do a lot of work from data training
to the prediction
so that's why uh we decided to have an i
mean uh to go from computational
approach to go go for an entirely based
based i mean entirely computational
approach to build
a particular protein protein interaction
network uh of the entire uh lish mania
proteome and integrate all the uh
interactive and proteomic data with one
another
so basically and of course uh this is uh
i mean this is right now my
current project so yes because of some
uh laboratory regulations i cannot
uh give very details about my current
project but yes i can give a very
uh brief
uh flow flow of
flow work
or the flowchart so is that the first
thing we need to uh we need to collect
is the reference proteome
so yes the reference proteome uh is
which is uh submitted in the uniprot uh
database
and uh
if in case of felispanian phantom
mainly uh we have
uh around eight eight thousand eight
thousand and forty five uh proteins
annotated in the entire proteome and the
similar number is also english mania
major
but uh one challenge is that we have
very very less knowledge about the
structures of these proteins
most of the most of the proteins and i
would say
uh very i mean more than 50 of these
proteins are hypothetical or just
computative proteins
so
the structure prediction in order to
build an interaction and
and finding an or predict that if two
proteins or more than proteins are
interacting or not is a very very um i
mean it is a very very important task
and of course
is uh i mean is a difficult task too
so and after the structure prediction
and after the structure after the thrust
of prediction uh we would also uh we
would also we have to also see that if i
mean whether the structure is uh i mean
whether the structure is very good or
not uh i mean depending on the
uh structural refinement and the
different different approaches uh taken
uh
by for for the structure prediction so
but yes uh once this structure
prediction is done we have to
and we are looking at particular
proteins uh if they are interact if they
are interactive or not with with each
other so these again protein
interactions uh can be classified
uh
based on different different parameters
like um
protein cellular localization uh then
coexpression and also most importantly
biological features and the
physiochemical properties
so and and here comes the particular
machine learning things because i said
that most of the proteins are
hypothetical proteins and if you go to
any particular protein database like
uniprot um you won't find uh any
any uh i mean information submitted uh
just only the sequence have been
submitted but yes
no other specific data is uh
has been submitted so therefore the
some machine learning algorithms like
you say support vector machine would
really be helpful in this case
to first uh classify the
protein sequences uh
based on different different parameters
like the biological
or biological features or physiochemical
properties
and then uh you have to look that if
really this protein
are interacting or not so here uh you
can again take two different steps one
thing you can just uh
you can just a doc protein you can just
have protein protein talking yes uh and
you know in a very large scale
and of course and then there are again
the machine learning algorithms uh which
uh
which can which can classify uh those
uh proteins on the best of their
predictive interactions
and after this protein interaction is
getting done uh we need to look at uh to
the cluster of the proteins and we need
to make it
in a particular
network of visualization to ultimately
form the protein protein interaction
network and of course when the network
is done we have to again um we have to
again measure the different parameters
of the network like the degree then the
number of nodes number of edges uh then
the
the betweenness centrality and then um
of course from which uh i mean from from
the network uh which is which are the
bottom left proteins or not we all
have to measure these things
so yes so
uh i would say like uh i mean as a
bioinformatics i mean student uh this is
uh quite challenging for me but yes this
is also
quite fascinating for me at the same
time and
the most important uh thing in
uh bioinformatics um or any uh or or
maybe any any project like this is that
you still you you always have a chance
to
learn and
upgrade yourself
so
that's uh briefly about myself and
how i
started my journey
thank you thank you so much
well thank you so much
that was really
fascinating to listen to us really just
as you said that there's always room for
you to learn as well as
get fascinated by what bioinformatics
can do and i'm really happy for you to
see that you have made such a great
progress and you have really
got involved in such
research work
might seem
a little bit frightening but i i am sure
that it's interesting as well thank you
so much for taking out your time from
your business schedule to be here and
share your expertise and knowledge with
us
it was great